in its death throes the the the mega
state is going to make a lot of mess and
the externalities from that are going to
be difficult to navigate through hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we're sitting down with Lois Rossetto
the co-founder of Wired and the co
recipient of the first-ever Lani
Friedlander award the reason has given
out thanks for talking to us Lois it's a
pleasure this is the 20th anniversary of
the founding of Wired your first issue
was January 1993 talk a little bit about
you know when you look back what did you
guys get right what did you get wrong
about the future it's a hard to cast
your mind back to that time 1993 we were
trying to raise the money at the end of
the Bush administration right and the
first Pacific Bush administration and
there the the number of computers that
were connected to the internet were in
the low millions and and we came out and
we said we launched in January 1993 and
we came out and we said that there's a
digital revolution happening and it was
going to change everything and the
people were making it happen were the
most powerful people on the planet
they're the people who are creating and
using digital technology and it wasn't
the priests in a pleasant pundits and
the politicians and the generals were
making positive change it was these
these people and that met a story it was
absolutely spot-on
so in lots of ways we were a mirror we
put up a mirror to a group of people who
had been obscure if not just ignored and
for other people it was sort of like a
window into a new world which they
didn't know about if you were looking if
you were reading the New York Times you
had no idea what was going on we had a
joke that the New York Times four years
after we launched had a continual series
of articles that they put on the front
page and other put the pages which were
essentially internet threat or menace
right where they just could not deal
with the changes that were going on do
you feel and I I mean this was a banal
question so I should withdraw it before
even asking it
but you know has the potential of the
internet you know has it come through or
where where is it like where have we
still not even tap the beginning of kind
of that world of and it's not about
computers it's really about
interconnectivity and the ability to
kind of envision something and then act
to make that real you know are we
preceding a pace are we going too slow
what are the sticking points and what
are the missed opportunities I'm
guessing we don't that we have arrived
at a point where we can't understand
what's really going on anymore
so the phenomena was a revolution a
digital revolution and it was about it
wasn't about computers it was about
brains being connected to brains through
digital communication aided by these
brain appliances we call it computers
and the value of that of those
connections the analogy is like a fax
machine
so one fax machine is useless - fax
machines start to have value when you
have lots of them the value the fax
machines is logarithmic it's not linear
anymore and I'm kind of excited that we
will have to explain what a fax machine
is the people under about 40 and what is
it I feel I remember seeing my first fax
of you out of a out of the machine from
a guy that was sending I was in
Amsterdam you're sending from California
is just stunned I said whoa but at this
point there are three billion people
connected to the internet which is still
only less than half of all humanity and
at the same time there are probably
multiple times that number of machines
connected to the right man
and tired the shardana talked about the
globe enrobing itself in a making itself
a brain out of electronic or electric
technology called it at the time and i
and i have the sense that already
there's a certain level of consciousness
that we can't perceive anymore anymore
than fish understand they're swimming in
the sea
that's that things are happening without
our control or knowledge is that a good
thing or a bad thing I mean cuz I mean
we're verging kind of into singularity
territory and I want to birth
so I'm sure that you as a teenager if
you would have thought that you as an
adult in quoting a Jesuit yeah a Jesuit
priest about the newest fear and whatnot
you'd be like what kind of where did my
life go wrong but right I mean is this
this is really what you're talking about
here is not a phenomenon that is either
good or bad it is simply the medium yeah
it is it's the universe the universe was
always out of our control and it's
always been unknowable the fact is now
that we're creating our own evolutionary
next step mm-hmm and since we're agents
of evolution ourselves right and I think
what's arriving is more is again
unknowable as we move into you know but
let's think about this in a kind of
institution or a framework sense we you
know we don't know where we're gonna end
up but clearly there are things that we
can do that are probably better or worse
right in in terms of decision making and
what are the types of large framework or
institutional decisions we should be
trying to impress upon our leaders or
ignoring from our leaders how do we
maximize the potential to create more
and kind of a post a post-scarcity world
and what are the things that can really
screw things up yeah well we've been
talking about this sort of meta
environment that were operating in but
nevertheless we still operate in it and
I guess one of the regrets I have for
for Wired is that throughout the time
that I was there and the digital
operations we did we tried to focus not
on politics and on government but on
those agents of change and those tools
and instruments which could make a
better world and I think to some degree
we had a certain amount of success with
that we had Clinton say at the end of
the year of big government was over and
I think there was a lot of focus on the
possibilities of creating a new future
for ourselves by ourselves right and it
really did seem that throughout the 90s
at least that you know and this is in
the wake of the collapse of the Soviet
Union and the end of the Cold War the
rise of computer industry yeah well and
the idea that politics wasn't going to
matter
as much right right and of course that
changed you know I mean I guess that's
always a dream but then after 9/11 and
whatnot it seemed like politics kind of
expanded now and we're we seem to be in
an era now where politics is very much
in the way because the way the
government spends the way it regulates
it gets in the way of everything well it
it always did but I think it's more it's
even more present in our life because
the media the the remnants of big media
tend to focus on it and because they're
advocates of it in general it becomes
the major story that they talk about I'm
not sure it's the real story I mean they
did the government has always been
dysfunctional it's always been the
producer of unintended consequences and
it's always you know made messes of all
sorts of stuff and that it's still doing
the same thing now I don't think much
much has changed what happened after
that after the 90s was a sort of
retrogression into the kind of primitive
political division that might have
characterized the 19th century the kind
of vitriolic and enemies that you or the
vitriol that you throw at your enemies
and it's become institutionalized and
you know it's interesting because I mean
this is something we read a lot about it
reason fewer people care about politics
in the sense that they're fewer people
are willing to identify as Liberty as
liberal or conservative Republican or
Democrat but the people who do the
dead-enders are like much more fiercely
committed to that as a primary identity
yeah I mean if you're a normal person
why would you want to engage in the mud
battles that are going on with with
basically psychopathic people you know
people who are who are involved in
politics by definition going back to
right Willhelm right right are emotional
cripples of some sort that are working
out their psychosis on the on the public
at large so why would a normal person
want to associate with that and let's be
clear Wilhelm Reich understood
psychopathology from the inside he was
an expert let's put it that way but
but to go back to the other to the
beginning of the question it's like what
so that was what went wrong I think
people devolved into politics again
where they started a step out of it the
message though is still the same that
and maybe even more pressing because the
digital revolution has been marching
through society and demolishing
institutions its left and right that
have been essential in lots of ways
whether it's education or whether it's
the court system or the police or
whatever they've been developed over
centuries and they're no longer relevant
or they're obsolete or they're
counterproductive or the destructive and
so there's a real need for something
else and what that something else is and
also an outgrowth of the digital
revolution is for citizens humans to
recapture the Civic space from those
institutions that have taken it over in
the 20th century to them for themselves
and if there is a future and a better
future it's going to be because
individuals and the family and their
institutions that they are groups that
they work with at whatever level decide
to take power back and work directly to
make that better better world are there
are there examples that you can point to
you know is YouTube that kind of space
is that a new public sphere that is more
participatory you know it's wholefoods
an improvement over you know an
old-style supermarket or what are what
are the types of demonstration projects
that are out there that kind of get your
get your energy up oh well I mean if you
just go back to the beginning of this
discussion where there were a few
million computers connected to the
internet now three billion people I at
the time was saying that there was a
discussion that was beginning that was
that was voices could be heard out there
in not for everybody three million three
billion people aren't gonna hear
everything but there would be groupings
of them that would hear things dialogue
would go on there would be back and
forth about it new consensuses would
evolve and disperse and evolve and
create and coalesce and and new kind of
consciousness would kind of it that was
consensual
and even that's not maybe even below the
level of a decision but nevertheless it
was moving things in a direction and I
think that that's really going on so I
mean and that's its it is tweet it's
YouTube it's all the places where
Instagram it's all the places where you
could have for one of a better word a
democratic kind of discussion words
unimpeded by the gatekeepers in Romania
that's an amazing step forward and
that's and that's also gives me hope
that the gatekeepers in the media are on
the way out in general because there's
the that there's a Rosetta law of media
which is it's a zero-sum game if you're
looking at Twitter or YouTube you're not
watching NBC or reading the New York
Times and so you're leaching attention
from them which is the thing they that
they need the most and in that in that
read read diversion of attention you
start to have a different kind of
political or idea environment than you
had before then you have now there's a
real future orientation not a not a kind
of bland utopianism but in in your
life's work and wired and whatnot talk a
little bit you've got kids do you when
you think about the future do you expect
that their future will be brighter than
yours was as yours was brighter than
your parents and grandparents or are you
you know do you wake up with fear and
trembling like what's gonna screw it all
up I I look at my own children and I
think they're capable of finding their
way in the world and succeeding no
matter what I worry that the environment
that they're gonna be operating in is
gonna be excuse me a lot more
challenging than it was for me in what
way because just I just I just think
that in its death throes the the the
mega state is going to make a lot of
mess and it's going to be hard to
navigate it's going to just the
externalities from that are going to be
difficult to navigate through so I think
they're they have the critical
facilities
understand what's happening which is
already a step forward being in touch
with reality is a important part of
being able to survive in an evolutionary
level but I think that the challenges
are going to be there they're gonna have
more challenges than they need to have
are you hopeful if people are more if
people have been more focused on you
know doing the right thing now how a
confident are you that we are and kind
of the death throes of the mega state or
is that is that the human condition that
at any you know kind of slice of time
that defines a human lifetime are we
always at the end of the mega state or I
think they are we really broaching you
know a historical limit here I think
that it's not as if the state's gonna go
away any more than churches went away I
just think that there hold on
imagination and and and and their the
authority that's given to them by the
public at large by humans and citizens
is gonna is gonna diminish that they are
proving themselves incapable and there
are other alternatives out there and I
think part of the challenge for media
for you guys or anyone else is to start
telling the other story because as long
as people think that they have to pay
attention to these guys that are
vibrating in Washington that the other
parts of the story which really deserve
attention and which really make
difference damn that's the other parts
of this story of what's going on in the
world today that's that's the real story
and yet we're obsessed like some kind of
a moth heading toward a fire with
another kind of story that's not the
right story and it's not a good story to
try to internalize well we'll leave it
there thank you so much for talking to
us lewis Rossetto co-fired co-founder of
Wired with Jane Metcalf co-recipient of
the first annual reasoned media Lifetime
Achievement Award the lani Friedlander
prize again with Jane Metcalf founder
co-founder of Cho chocolate thanks so
much for talking to reason it's been a
pleasure for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie